Hey,
wise,
crack.
Jared here.
Full disclosure,
this video was made possible by the
people over at for.
We've been fans of the Mondo show,
happy tree friends for a while,
so when verve reached out to us and
asked us to check out the new Mondo
show,
Gary and his demons streaming
exclusively on verb.
We were pretty excited and five episodes
in.
We couldn't help but notice a lot of
similarities to to otherwise crack
favorites archer and this show that
we've mentioned maybe once or twice
before.
Don't hate one particular moment stood
out to us as particularly zeitgeisty.
When it comes to murdering people,
I guess you could say.
Why don't you say,
I guess you could say here.
That's what you're going to say.
That's not what I was going to say.
Pretty sure it is.
Oh,
it's not your whole personality.
His hooks,
man.
There's other things you can say.
All right.
Which reminded us of this.
God,
would you give it a rest?
Damn,
I had something to this and this.
I guess I did the Butler.
Does it?
Does that scan?
This subversion of hero one liners got
us thinking,
why is this kind of humor so prevalent
these days?
Is there something more going on here
that says something about our modern
social condition,
and as we watched more,
we realized that was just the tip of the
iceberg,
so if you haven't seen Gary and his
demons yet,
check out [inaudible] dot co slash wise,
crack birth 30 day free trial and join
us as we impart on a time honored,
wise crack tradition over explaining a
joke for the sake of social commentary.
One thing we've noticed lately is a
particular trend in comedy,
subjecting the fantastic to the mundane
in rick and morty.
Be Fanciful Tale of Jack and the
beanstalk is taken down a peg.
When the narrative becomes mired in
legal proceedings,
be horrifying.
Freddy Kruger has the same marital woes
and performance anxiety as your average
club and even the post apocalypse still
has suburban domestic spats.
Dang,
Dang.
Wow.
Everybody hear that
in archer,
these secret agent fantasy of blowing up
and womanizing is subjected to the
realities of expense reports.
Some serious discrepancies in your
account,
I'm sure you wouldn't use operational
funds for personal expenses.
HR,
most of my jobs dealing with sexual
harassment complaints against Mr Archer
and hearing loss.
What Barry,
what?
We don't have any pepper.
Earplugs.
You idiot.
You know how bad that is for your
eardrums.
Gary and his demons does the same.
Subjecting demon hunting to the mundane
activities of office life and sock
puppets.
You'd be comfortable talking to my
friend.
Suck Guy Suck.
Why does this comedy works so well and
why now?
Or at least for adult cartoon viewers
between the ages of 18 and 34.
Well to overly dramatic one could say
it's because our dreams are dead still
with me.
Good.
Because to understand why we're going to
have to dive into the philosophy of
humor.
There are a few major theories of humor
out there,
but one that popped up only a few
hundred years ago is incongruent.
Basically the idea that humor arises
from the discrepancy between our
expectations and reality.
I mean,
what is a punchline,
if not the subversion of our
expectation?
Remember we used to smoke pot and then
talk about how one day maybe we could be
on Conan together.
Yeah,
that was yesterday,
but
there's one philosopher who takes this
further,
arguing that humor arises from the
[inaudible] between our notion of
ourselves as humans and the subversion
of that notion by the mechanical nature
of our lives.
While this theory is a bit antiquated,
we can use it to help us understand
humor.
Today in 1900 philosopher Henri Bergson
theorized that the source of humor was
the mechanical encrusted upon the human
writing during the industrial
revolution.
Bergson said,
when we laugh because someone falls,
it's not necessarily their misfortune
that we find funny,
but the spectacle of a machine
malfunctioning.
In this case,
our bodies,
for example,
take the classic prank of pulling a
chair out from under a friend about to
sit.
They fall on their ass.
Hilarity ensues.
According to Bergson,
we laughed because an action,
as routine as sitting down is basically
the body on autopilot.
Seeing that habitual emotion fail is
what generates the lows,
and while this kind of falling on your
ass humor certainly predates machines.
We can still think of it in terms of
mechanical rigidity against human
flexibility.
It's probably no coincidence that
Bergson was writing when factories and
machines reshaped modern life.
More than 30 years later,
Charlie Chaplin would in some ways
embody elements of Bergson's theory in
modern times where the intrusion of
mechanization onto the human is put
front and center.
If modern times was so popular,
was it because he struck a nerve with
people's relationship to machines for
chaplain?
It's not just that humans are acting
like machines,
but have also become entangled in a
society of machines which brings us to
modern day.
We no longer feel our sense of self
threatened by physical machines,
but another kind of machine you see
Bergson's formulation has evolved.
Humor isn't just the machine and crusted
upon the human society and crusted upon
the human,
the component parts of society,
state and corporate bureaucracy,
cultural expectations all act like a
kind of machine.
One that happens to simultaneously feed
us dreams and tear them away from us.
The discrepancy between our fantasies
that helped us cope with reality and the
reality that forsakes those dreams is
the new engine of humor.
In 2018,
Gary and his demons imagines a chosen
demon hunter as a sad sack working stiff
who can't even retire.
I realized why,
I mean all the time it's of my job sucks
and my life
sucks more than anyone else's and that's
navel gazing.
That is the truth.
Demons have to face being in or out like
fashion trends
that hot new mirror monster running his
mouth about how the old guard is out of
touch.
Bloody Mary dates back to the 15
hundreds,
mira monster,
and in archer.
Even the exciting world of espionage
won't take your mind off your flex
account.
I got to spend the balance of my God
damn flex account
and while Rick may be the only one above
it all,
I mean he's not bogged down by expense
reports and bureaucracy net bureaucrats.
I don't respect them.
Just keep shooting morning his arch
nemesis or a bunch of himself that
reduce other versions of himself to
factory workers and students.
The whole joke of simple rick is
revealing the real nature of escapist
fantasy as just another cog in the
soulless machine come home to the unique
flavor of shattering the grand illusion.
Come home to simple rick,
and it's not just these three shows.
This kind of humor is everywhere.
The good place imagines an afterlife
full of legal,
arbitration and Algorithms.
When your time on earth has ended,
we calculate the total value of your
life.
He was saying are perfectly accurate
measuring system only.
The people with the very highest scores,
the true cream of the crop got to come
here to the good price.
One Punch man imagined super heroing as
a dumb bureaucratic game mired in red
tape and the sleeper hit soon to be TV.
Show what we do in the shadows envisions
frightening vampires fighting over banal
roommate issues.
Vampires don't do dishes to return to
Berkson.
If we find all this funny,
it's because we're confronted with a
mirror of our own lives.
More than just laughing at bodies as
machines,
we laugh when we imagine people as mere
instruments have a greater machine.
Bergson gives the example of a person
who performs their duty,
not like a human,
but like a machine.
He cites a story he found in a
newspaper.
A large steamer was wrecked off the
coast of France after courageously
rushing to save the passengers.
The customs officers didn't ask if the
survivors were okay,
but rather immediately asked if they had
anything to declare.
The customs officers were not acting as
humans,
but mere instruments have a larger
bureaucracy,
and this is exactly what shows like
archer Gary and his demons and sometimes
rick and morty rely on how we've become
near instruments have a larger game.
We know how you feel.
We're working.
Our assembly line is justice.
It puts on display the inclusivity
between the way we imagine the world
ought to be and the way it really is
because of this discrepancy.
We no longer live in a world where we
can stomach the cheery idealism of
heroes past,
but have to deconstruct the fantasy at
every turn because our fantasies have
been deconstructed.
We can't imagine much of anything
without wanting to think of what is
pulling its strings.
Take these superhero one liner,
one say,
source of Catharsis.
If it got motherfucker,
it now needs to be exposed as a tired
cliche.
So we get this
table for one.
Want to try?
Want to try one more time?
Um,
this guy's cut off
beause you know this.
You should know that as an original and
this Gillette,
she'd be ready with the transdermal
solution of the most powerful laxative
known to man.
Damn man,
I had something for this.
Marvel movies can't sell superheroes
without constantly undercutting the
seriousness of what they're doing.
We know other.
He's a friend from work
pools,
one of the most popular superheroes by
virtue of not being a hero at all,
and things like cinema since draw humor
from subjecting films to a level of
cold,
hard logic that they weren't even built
for.
This leads us to the second marker of
modern humor,
a broken protagonist.
Now this certainly isn't new.
Jerry Seinfeld did it over 20 years ago,
but instead of looking up to burt
reynolds,
now admire a broken version of burt
reynolds or a broken van,
helsing or a broken doc brown.
And then there's something like,
it's always sunny in Philadelphia,
a show that according to create or Glenn
Howerton shows what the American dream
looks like when you fail.
Even the notion of doing good deeds,
his shadow on relishing in the
collateral damage that often comes with
being a quote.
Good guy are demon hunter amputates an
orphan by accident and tries to be a
nicer person before realizing it's
pointless.
You came,
oh,
I knew you cared about me.
You are a good guy.
Similarly,
morty tries to save an interdimensional
being from assassination only to
discover it wants to exterminate all
life.
Carbon based life is a threat tool I
allies to us.
You are what you would call a disease
and has to kill it himself.
Rick highlights the futility of do
gooding when he says,
what about the reality where Hitler
cured cancer?
Morty,
the answer is don't think about it.
And the entire premise of archer is to
explore these self obsessed
eccentricities of the people who are
supposed to keep us safe at night.
To summarize,
we were promised jet packs and hover
boards.
And because we never got them,
we have no fantasies,
no heroes,
and some serious skepticism about doing
good.
And now the best sense of pleasure we
can get is collectively reflecting on
that sense of disappointment.
Now,
that's not to say we're completely
without dreams.
Instead of dreaming of Nicer cars and
the perfect relationship,
which shirt definitely still happens.
We also get gratification by relishing
in the utterly mundane.
Would you rather get embroiled in a
particularly nasty Ponzi scheme or go on
a date with trevor from school?
Things like the Roy game or this are
barely even science fiction.
She's obsessed with her new virtual
bouncer game.
Real fun.
You on the list?
Nice tripe house to the back of the
line.
Is it any different than the wildly
popular job simulator game where one
pretends to be a robot,
poorly reenacting mundane office work or
clicker games,
but is everything hopeless?
Of course not.
Yes we wise crackers can sometimes seem
like curmudgeons,
but hey,
that's what happens when you read
philosophy,
Bro.
But I promise there's still hope like my
dog.
What do you look at?
Dead baby phase muffin man.
Oh,
or for instance,
I went to this place that took my two
favorite sauces,
hummus and garlic sauce,
and turned it into one sauce.
It pretty much shattered my worldview.
So look,
how can you fixate on the hopelessness
of the modern condition when there are
still breakthroughs made everyday in sos
technology and for more good old
fashioned distractions,
check out new episodes of Gary and his
demons on verb every Sunday by going to
[inaudible] dot co slash wise crack.
Whether you're online or offline,
you can watch gary and a bunch of other
great animated shows on verve like
Freakazoid,
bravest warriors,
deep space 69,
and be in puppy cap also if you're in
anime,
ferb has the best subbed and dubbed
shows,
including my hero,
academia,
dragon,
super black clover and food wars.
Thanks [inaudible] for giving us this
opportunity and as always,
guys,
thanks for watching.
Peace.